entre un bateau français est un bateau
anglais la rencontre peut être tendu la
pêche source de conflit entre la france
et le royaume uni depuis dès décennies
malgré les différentes décisions de la
communauté européenne
il est décidément bien difficile de
s'entendre avec les anglais sur les
règlements européens l'europe permettent
aux pays membres d'aller pêcher dans les
eaux étrangères au sein de la communauté
ce qui n'empêche pas chaque nation
d'avoir ces règles sur son territoire en
1979 alors que les anglais font partie
de la communauté européenne depuis six
ans ils distribuent des amendes aux
bateaux français parce qu'ils jugent
leur fils est trop fin les pêcheurs
bretons on appelle alors à la cour
européenne
on demande la tamise et tous les frais
le manque à gagner
fin des années 70 les conflits se répète
les ministres de la pêche de tous les
pays membres se réunissent leurs
solutions en 1983 c'est l'europe bleus
une politique commune sur 20 ans enfin
une bonne nouvelle à l'actif de l'europe
communautaire vingt ans après la
politique agricole commune l'europe de
la pêche est née la politique de pêche
commune c'est préserver la ressource
établir des quotas de pêche et instaurer
l'égalité d'accès aux bateaux de tous
les pays mais pas de quoi calmer la
concurrence en mer ils ont
volontairement ignorée à la position de
mes finnair et ont contourné le bateau
et puis délibérément couper les filets
en 1992
roussel réajuste la politique de
l'europe bleus pour préserver davantage
la ressource
lui encore en 2002 depuis les conflits
se concentrent dans les eaux
internationales
je ne comprends pas nous dit ce pêcheur
anglais je suis dans les eaux
internationales et j'ai le droit de
pêcher en quittant l'union le royaume
uni devrait reprendre le contrôle de ses
eaux les plus riches en poissons de robe
les pêcheurs français seraient ainsi
privés de 30% de leurs captures actuelle
pas de quoi noyer la hache de guerre en
mer
[Musique]